le monastère notre dame de l'atlas est
le dernier site chrétiens d'algérie où
l'on ait entendu sonner les cloches car
aujourd'hui les églises font silence
c'est ici que les sept moines trappistes
ont été enlevés à une heure du matin
les groupes islamistes armés sont très
actives dans cette région de montagne
une centaine d'entre eux auraient été
tués dans des accrochages ces trois
derniers jours précisément dans cette
région de médéa où a eu lieu
l'enlèvement
parmi les sept trappistes enlevés se
trouve le père supérieur christian de
chergé mais les hommes voulaient surtout
enlever le frère médecin afin qu'ils
soignent un de leurs blessés tous les
religieux savaient le danger qu'il
courait septembre 93 le massage des
croates qui est tout juste à côté d'eux
c'était des croates chrétiens qui allait
au monastère dont la question s'est
posée ce moment là depuis ce temps là il
ya eu onze religieux religieuses
constituent normalement deux par deux
dans les lieux où ils travaillaient
normalement
à chaque fois la question s'est posée
alors il s'agit de savoir est ce que on
continue notre présence de témoignages
ou bien si on fait le jeu des débits
allant dans la nuit de noël
il ya deux ans le cours un groupe était
venu au par m durant la nuit ça va
réunit tous les frères et il avait exigé
des frères une collaboration
collaboration au point de vue du médecin
qui devra aller dans la montagne point
de vue argent et
quel point fut aussi et les frères en
refusant dit non nous ne pouvons pas
depuis 93 11 religieux dont sept
français ont été tués dans des attentats
mais ces hommes et ces femmes de foi ont
tous décidé de continuer d'aider la
population algérienne
près de 300 religieux étrangers vivrait
encore en algérie mais régulièrement ils
enterrent l'un des leurs l'enlèvement
des sept religieux français montre les
limites de l'action du nouveau
gouvernement qui avait promis que la
paix civile reviendrai après l'élection
présidentielle
une vaste battue a commencé dans les
montagnes qui dominent de monastères
c'est ici que les commandos du groupe
islamique armé ont enlevé les sept
religieux français il aurait été conduit
dans l'une des caches que les islamistes
possède ici
les membres du gia dont la des chefs
étaient blessés avaient besoin d'un
médecin
le père paul dort chez qui soignait les
combattants pendant la guerre
d'indépendance et l europe
les deux moines qui ont échappé à
l'enlèvement devait regagner alger ce
soir malgré l'assassinât de sang neuf
étrangers quelques 300 religieux ont
décidé de rester comme le père lafitte
qui vit ici depuis 30 ans à des
questions de ma famille j'ai répondait
souvent que c'est pas au moment où
quelqu'un est malade qu'on lui lâche la
main on reste avec et je creuse et j'ai
connu des moments très heureux ici
les vents sont plus difficiles et je
compte bien continuer à partager ces
moments là avec mes amis l'émotion reste
grande chez les moines de l'abbaye
d'aiguebelle qui ne croyait pas aux
enlèvements
ces deux là qu'était partie le père
supérieur christian de chergé arrêter
avec les six autres religieux du
monastère de tibéhirine
ils sont dans une population au milieu
des populations de gens qui subissent le
régime actuel et elle ne voulait pas
quitter cette population à laquelle ses
frères étaient très attachés notamment
parce que la 1 2 degrés plus de 50 ans
était médecin est quand médecins et aux
services à vocation locale l'enlèvement
du frère médecin n'explique pas celui
des six autres moines sauf si les
groupes islamiques armés ont décidé de
supprimer toute présence chrétienne dans
cette région d'algérie
voilà monsieur bonsoir c'est par
l'intermédiaire d'un journal proche des
milieux intégristes que le gia
le groupe islamique armé a fait savoir
aujourd'hui qu'il était en fait l'auteur
de l'enlèvement des sept moines
trappistes français disparus en algérie
il y à un mois
le gia se propose de libérer ces
religieux qui serait toujours en vie en
échange de militants prisonniers
notamment en france gilles rabin depuis
un mois malgré le ratissage systématique
de cette montagne de l'atlas par l'armée
algérienne
on restait sans nouvelle des sept moines
trappistes du monastère de tibhirine
enlevés le 27 mars dernier par un
commando islamiste non identifié ce
matin un journal publié à londres al
hayat site sur sa une un communiqué du
gia qui revendique l'enlèvement demande
au gouvernement français à jacques
chirac d'échangé contre des membres du
gia emprisonné en france
les sept moines sinon conclut le
communiqué nous les tuerons ce
communiqué n'est pas très rassurant
puisque il menace d'exécuter les moines
si on ne répond pas à leurs demandes et
qui sont pas d'ailleurs très précises
entre nous pour le moment on ne peut que
continuer de crier et
est ainsi fier notre prière peut-être ne
se sentent ils pas contenté de prier
toujours d'après le journal al hayat des
instances catholiques italiennes et
françaises seraient en contact depuis la
mi-avril avec les ravisseurs des sept
moines de tibérine c'est ce journaliste
spécialisé dans les affaires algériennes
pour al hayat qui a publié le premier le
communiqué dont l'authenticité ne fait
aucun doute
al ansar organe officieux du gia publie
le même texte dans sa 148e édition
sortie cet après-midi highway je suppose
et ce n'est que mon interprétation ce
n'est basée sur aucune information
concrète que des négociations secrètes
qui se seraient tenues en algérie entre
les ravisseurs et la france ont échoué
frantz hypothèse en forme de question
la réponse ne se trouvera pas à londres
mais peut-être à alger ou à paris déjà
hier soir dans un geste très fort le
cardinal lustiger avait annoncé
l'effroyable nouvelle en éteignant et
hier soir les sept cierges les cierges
qui symbolisait la vie des sept
trappistes enlevés le 27 mars
le texte du gia était toujours alors en
cours d'authentification mais les
experts déjà n'avait guère de doute
françois cordet le texte daté du 21 mai
portant le numéro 44 et de cachets
habituel du gia est signée par le chef
présumé du groupe islamique armé jamais
lé site uni il accuse le président
français le ministre des affaires
étrangères d'avoir déclaré je cite ne
pas vouloir négocier avec le gia
le 30 avril trente quatre jours après
l'enlèvement des sept moines trappistes
dans leur monastère
nous avons envoyé poursuit de
communiquer un message et à l'ambassade
de france à alger
porteur d'une cassette audio confirmant
que les sept religieux étaient vivants
et un message précisant la façon de
négocier pour obtenir leur libération
l'ambassade précise le communiqué nous a
écrit une lettre signée et cachetée
affirmant qu'elle voulait préserver cet
accord nous avons donc pensé dans un
premier temps que la france tenait à la
vida sept moines
fin de citation malgré ces tractations
secrètes
les forces de sécurité algériennes
poursuivre leur chasse à l'homme
en vain
selon l'évêque d'oran les ravisseurs
seraient venus à tibéhirine pour emmener
un seul moine médecin afin de soigner
des islamistes blessés
les religieux français avait choisi de
continuer à vivre dans leur monastère
dans une région de maquis du gia
malgré la présence des moudjahidine
qu'ils avaient surnommés les frères de
la montagne le second mobile de
l'enlèvement des sept moines révélé le
26 avril dernier par le quotidien arabe
al hayat et l échange proposé aux
autorités françaises des sept otages
contre la libération des militants du
gia emprisonnés et notamment abdelhak
layada ancien dirigeant du groupe
condamné à mort et détenu en algérie les
sept moines français avaient été enlevés
dans leur habit le 27 mars dernier
depuis aucune nouvelle le gouvernement
français dément avoir entamé une
négociation tout au plus
des contacts avaient été pris les
assassins affirment eux qu'ils avaient
clairement transmis au gouvernement
français leurs exigences dans une casse
est parvenu à l'ambassade de france à
alger dominic thiem authenticité
probable crédibilité totale
c'est ainsi que les autorités françaises
qualifie ce document attribué au gia il
annonce et hier l'assassinât des sept
moines trappistes enlevés le 27 mars
dernier en algérie
le communiqué précisait alors des
éléments jusqu'ici inconnue le 30 avril
96 et on dans le texte
un émissaire remettait à l'ambassade de
france à alger une cassette audio
prouvant que les moines étaient toujours
en vie
cette information est aujourd'hui
confirmée par le quai d'orsay il est
exact qu'à cette date des documents nous
ont été adressées documents faisant état
du fait que les religieux était encore
en vie quelques jours plus tôt le
document audio remis à l'ambassade de
france a été enregistrée le 20 avr
en fond sonore un bulletin d'information
radio permet d'authentifier cette date
les moines otages se présentent tour à
tour distinctement
si vous ne négociez pas distille ils
vont nous tuer
ils reprennent aussi les termes du
communiqué publié deux jours plus tôt le
18 avril dans une revue proche du gia
les preneurs d'otages y exigeaient la
libération de prisonniers détenus en
france ainsi que celles d'abdelhak
layada un des chef du gia emprisonnés en
algérie à paris pendant deux mois
la direction de la sécurité du
territoire a été mobilisé le général
rondot expert aguerri a fait de nombreux
voyages en algérie
le dernier remonte à quelques jours mais
officiellement pas question de
négociation les contacts avaient été
pris
j'ai ri mais il n'y a pas eu de
négociations il ne peut pas y avoir de
négociation
comment voulez vous qu'on envisage un
seul instant de la russie avec des
assassins aussi barbare stupeur affirmé
tiers le premier communiqué des
autorités françaises le mot était
choisie apparemment rien ne laissait
entrevoir l'imminence d'une issue trajet
madame monsieur bonsoir une messe
solennelle a été célébrée cet après midi
à alger en la basilique notre dame
d'afrique en mémoire des sept moines
trappistes assassinés par le gia dont le
souvenir a été associé à celui du
cardinal d'alger monseigneur duval
décédé cette semaine
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
verdict avoué crise tout en vous
demandant de tendre l'oreille
un dispositif de sécurité impressionnant
unité d'élite groupe commando armée
gendarmerie police
notre dame d'afrique sous très haute
surveillance pour une cérémonie comme la
basilique n'en avait jamais connu une
heure avant le début de la messe les
dépouilles des sept moines arrivée en
ambulance dans le silence et le
recueillement
1 1 les cercueils ont été transportés à
l'intérieur de la basilique sur chacun
d'eux une couronne de fleurs et un ruban
aux couleurs de la france une messe en
hommage aux sept moines trappistes
assassiné mais également une messe pour
le cardinal duval l'homme du dialogue
islamo-chrétien représentant du pape et
présence exceptionnelle ici du cardinal
lustiger
l'archevêque de paris a tenu à se
recueillir un instant devant la baie
d'alger
la communauté catholique est venue
nombreuse en cette journée du souvenir
présence également d'armes aideraient
yahia le premier ministre algérien et de
plusieurs membres du gouvernement ainsi
que d'une partie de la classe politique
algérienne émotion à l'intérieur de la
basilique sur chaque cercueil le
portrait de chaque moines assassinés et
celui du cardinal duval fidélité à leur
engagement le message ce soir de
monseigneur teissier archevêque d'alger
[Musique]
vim
rapprochement entre les deux communautés
catholique et musulmane
c'est le message que les autorités
religieuses d'alger ont tenu à faire
passer au delà de la violence qui a
frappé les moines de tibérine c'est un
engagement que nous tiens il ya cinq ans
jour pour jour la france apprenait le
martyre des sept moines de tibéhirine
enlevés et assassinés dans la région de
médéa
cinq ans après la lumière se fait peu à
peu sur les conditions de leur
disparition
en fait c'est une lutte d'influencé
entre deux différents groupes islamiques
armés qui auraient provoqué le drame
notre envoyé spécial faouzia fait qui
rit a rencontré le chef de l'un de ces
deux groupes l'hiver dernier à quelques
kilomètres du monastère désormais dr ali
belhadj arrêt le chef d'un groupe
dissident du géant
il retrace ce parcours des sept moines
trappistes massacré ya cinq ans à 100 km
d'alger pouvant se trouve juste sous le
brouillard
c'est ici qu'ils les ont emmenés vers le
refuge
et c'est là bas qu'ils les ont tués ils
ont laissé leur tête sur la route
nationale près de médéa
les sept moines vivaient dans ce
monastère enlevé le 27 mars 96
ils ont été exécutés 56 jours plus tard
le 21 mai 96 à massacre revendiqué dans
ce communiqué signé par le chef du gia
djamel zitouni
d'après ali benhadjar lui-même
extrémistes cet acte sanglant a provoqué
la rupture avec site uni italie et son
groupe compte attaquer tout ce qui
bougeait y compris les moines trappistes
pourtant nos premiers chefs avaient
conclu il ya bien longtemps un pacte de
confiance avec ces religieux on appelle
cela le hamman impact qui consistait à
ne pas toucher aux moines
en échange de soins médicaux aux
combattants blessés
rené guitton vient de publier un livre
sur le martyre des moines de tibhirine
pour l'écrivain ils étaient devenus les
otages d'une lutte fratricide zitouni
essayé d'organiser son pouvoir façon
hégémonique et à défier et a ordonné à
belhadj hard enlevé les moines
sauf que belhadj ans ne voulait pas est
ce qu'on a c'est devenu un enjeu de
pouvoir entre ces deux groupes
et lorsque ben el hadj a refusé de les
enlever et bien dit o'neal ray exécuté
par ses propres hommes
cet enlèvement
et le 21 mai 96 les sept moines se
retrouvé décapité
alors dans le maquis le groupe d' ali
benhadjar décide de régler le problème
et unis de façon radicale ces munitions
avec le fusil mitrailleur ont été
récupérés au cours d'une embuscade que
nous avons dressé à djamel zitouni le 16
juillet 96 on l'a tué avec deux de ses
lieutenants
ceci est donc le but a ramené par les
combattants ont mené cette embuscade
contre le gia et dieu nous a aidé à
battre djamel zitouni la tête du gia
nous en sommes enfin débarrassé à paris
un général français fut lui aussi
satisfait de cette exécution à ses yeux
justice était faite
présent au quai d'orsay durant la
gestion de la crise cet homme avait pu
mesurer toute l'incompétence des
autorités françaises à faire libérer les
otages
navré par une telle inertie le militaire
avait même proposé de prendre la place
des sept moines aujourd'hui ce sont les
hommes les plus dures du gia qui
contrôle cette zone
la population a fui malgré deux
tentatives
aucun moine n'est jamais revenue vivre
dans le monastère de tibhirine désormais
dr
[Musique]